thank you
[Music]
so the Guinness World Record has been
broken for the world's longest kiss how
long do you think that kid whoa okay 24
hours over 20 over 24 hours over 24
hours who gives a [__] yeah nobody gives
it it just lips to lip or is it an
actual French kiss like
yeah I think it's just lip to lip like
contact between the lips as long as you
don't stop lip to lip a week
it's got to be more than 24 hours but it
can't be a week dude I hope there are
lips they're just [__] they just keep
this here and then they're just taking
food in their nose yeah they go like
this and they can put food in here like
this here's the here's the queen oh
are those Asian people they look like
they're smooching parkour yeah they're
literally sucking each other it does not
look fun though 37 hours though
um oh it's a Thai couple if they're
Asian it's a it's twice as long as than
I thought because they got crazy
discipline yeah that's that's a good uh
prediction it they make a game out of
suffering yeah they're good at suffering
they go two weeks too easy the record is
now 58 hours whoa get a job so that
whole time did they fast
enough two and a half days can you
imagine them going to the bathroom like
this yeah dude honey you go first okay
now I go their lips must be like
destroyed oh my God
they were they were actually competing
against other couples they don't make
the time they gotta do it yeah what are
the rules like are they allowed to like
take a break and go oh right I don't
know I don't think it's separate yeah
just nose breathing I think you just
gotta deal with it but yeah they were so
there's other couples doing it too some
of them are fainting straight up
at least we know that like they were
they standing too the whole time can you
lay down I I'm not sure if they you
could lay down they better I hope they
don't that means they didn't sleep or
you think they slept through the kiss oh
you have to stand yeah it says you have
to stand oh my God
for 58 hours
oh dude it says yeah you have to um
food and liquid through a straw while
you're kissing and you have to go piss
while you're kissing oh you know what's
crazy too
point in time your breath just stinks oh
your breath just stink yeah cause you
got morning breath damn dude that's
crazy all kinds of slime but maybe that
also like really deepens your love yeah
I guess after this I probably wouldn't
kiss for the next three years because it
made up for all the years of kissing the
um crazy this is how good we have it as
humans dude we can just do this stupid
[__] like this and it's like we're gonna
get we're gonna worry about tigers
eating us or anything hey the prize
um 50 bucks
um
the second place couple is like a gay
couple that didn't get it by like two
minutes or something oh they were like
oh they're like
uh and we're out yeah because I thought
the the they would go for longer so no
one could beat them I bet two dudes is a
good is a good combination to win a race
like this easier to pee yeah yeah easier
just logistically yeah but yeah they
they collapsed like they didn't even
like it wasn't like they were like huh
they like actually finished his body
just couldn't take it off at that point
the people who were dropping out are
physically like wow dropping out yeah I
don't even think David Gotti needs to do
some [__] like this
it's [__] crazy dude if you tell
David Goggins though to do it I think
he'd go like all right I have to do it I
know hey but when you guys were like
virgins and [__] I could do that [__]
all day when you guys were making out
pretty long I would have been I would
have busted nuts 20 000 times 58 hours
if I was a virgin but you're kissing
pretty [__] long right it was a
competition for dry humping your boy's
winning
because you don't know
but isn't that funny like back then you
would just you would just kiss so much
because like there you don't know how to
like get to the next level exactly it
would kiss for hours you just scanned by
the parking lot dude that felt good
though it did yeah it was cool well not
58 hours bro what's the first time you
like made out made out in the movie
theaters how did you know what to do
she led the way and she gave me hookies
hickies
we were on a double dump with their
older sister
behind like oh yeah
we were on a double date with their
older sister do you remember the movie
no I don't remember we're making out the
whole movie she was sucking on my neck
that's a HomeTown favorite in between
her thighs oh [__] it's so forward I
know damn well I was she was older I was
14 and she was 16. so that's my
experience still even as a 16 year old
that's gangster a boner the whole time
of course you did what else to do if you
did it yeah I'd be real worried
what's up
dude I gotta kick your ass but you know
like the whole time it was also
uncomfortable because we're like that
was back in the day when the the the the
seats were smaller but you're like
you're doing one of these things right
yeah and then like I was so embarrassed
to adjust my dick oh like now I just do
it but back then it's like like no one
but back then you didn't want to like
touch that area at the same time because
you just don't know and then like it's
all comfortable you got a Jeep you're
worthy she was gonna get pregnant if you
touch your penis dude you're pregnant
you get pregnant you don't want to do
that that's cross-contamination yeah but
I was just like I don't know what's
happening and then I think it was like
the first time for so many things like
like the the the the the the the the
over the over the panties rubbing yeah
and then the [__] hickey at the same
time and making out for such a long time
uh everything just happening at once and
I was like damn I thought it's like
racing uh yeah it wasn't in stages it
wasn't good at multitasking I want to
get like a slow kiss you kind of gotta
yeah like this and then maybe a hickey
did you come out of the movies that's a
lot of things at one time I got orgied
in the ones like that's like I was like
a big that's fast time yeah what's the
longest you ever made out with somebody
Colleen
as a without 10 year old without going
to the next level like just kissing I
don't think I ever like timed it but I
could assume you gotta time it through
movies the first time you made it with
someone did you make a move
did I make the movie yeah
um I think I make most of my moves whoa
Modern Woman Modern Woman let's go dude
it's Americans you make most of your
movies I would say most of my moves as a
kid or as a teenager I would say yeah
were you with boys that were too slow
you're like come on kiss me already a
loser but what's the duration no I would
say maybe
[Music]
like 15 20. seconds
imagine you making most of moves is kind
of funny did you ever do the hold the
collar and the fist kiss me
excuse me dude
I could just tell like if I didn't make
the move then it wasn't gonna happen and
I liked the person and I felt like he
was nervous so I just felt like it'd be
easier for me to make them move so that
way because you knew he liked yeah
that's probably why I got my hand
between her thighs because I was she put
you there I just wanted it
scared I was like I didn't know you like
it like that yeah yeah I was like I
didn't know you like me like that
because normally it's like it like
incrementally over time yeah dating a
lot of more but you know what though
girls get exposed way [__] quicker
than dudes do I feel like all the girls
lost their virginities like from 12 to
16 and guys lost it from like 15 to
older at least not to be a discrepancy
event because if I do the math correctly
no because the girls you like older
dudes the older Dukes younger girls all
the time and then so that's why I think
in most my cases like they were way more
bold because I also had that rule where
like if I'm gonna lose my virginity she
has to be a virgin too yeah we want to
trade cards yeah but then
that's how I wanted it because I
remember this girl I wasn't even she
wasn't even my girlfriend but we're
fooling around and then she came in she
was all like I'm not
and I was like
take my DVDs I no I I took that as ooh
you're naughty
just like
me neither
what age what age did you first make out
make out make out dang no late dude I
don't think I started making out making
until like my senior year
senior year of elementary school
[Laughter]
yeah no like high school I'm talking
making out what we're talking like for
like hours you know what I mean we're
just like discovering what an experience
right where you didn't know how to
breach to the next level or you you just
would make out for a long time I had no
idea when it was going to be the first
time and it was at the Performing Arts
Center in our in our high school your
move her move [__] dude honestly we were
just in the middle of like watching a
play and it was dark and then you know
we were laughing at something that was
going on and I was just already like it
was kind of dumb because I didn't know
what the situation was but we've been
hanging out you know what I mean a lot
we've been talking a lot but I wasn't
really paying attention to like that and
that's probably why it was also a really
fun relationship because we were just
good friends and then you know it just
got dark laughing outside she kind of
like kissed me on the cheek and I was
like whoa It's all these girls making
the first move hey girl yeah just better
yeah well it's also like guys are you're
in that moment too you're also trying
not to you've never been it before but
you're trying desperately not to be an
[__] yeah you don't know what that is
but you overshoot that so hard yeah yeah
you know what I mean did you hear about
all the scumbags who you don't want to
be a scumbag but but this girl like
gives even [__] half of a percent
yeah you feel like the whole doors get
to open up and the whole thing changes
then you fingerbreak them with their
tongue did you guys ever ask can I kiss
you did you know how to do that no
that's crazy I never asked I think first
move was always
touching like my first move would be
like holding cuddling hand holding right
and then like but then the kissing would
be the girl oh so she's like aggressive
enough to like now the ball's in your
court you get to decide if or maybe I
just didn't make the move fast enough
because I'm just like I'm just like
holding her hand and I'm like this is
nice I like that and then she's like
thinking man you slow son of a [__]
kiss me already this is [__]
[__] I'm gonna show you some
real [__] all right let's just go it can
help me practice for my CPR
recertification please that's a good one
wow I also need to practice
that's sexy that's Luther Vandross dang
that's some prom King [__] right there
dude yo baby can I give you a look
it's getting worse that was pretty
masculine that's what I like but the
fifth time he asked I've already left
he's saying it to himself he's like he's
workshopping it if you don't know and if
you have to ask isn't that already weird
yes
if I'm already there on a date if we've
already spent a lot of time together
we've already it's like the progression
of like intimacy you should be
comfortable already you're comfortable
yeah you know what I think it is in high
school like you don't know what's a
formal date because you know hanging out
after school and trying to spend time
with like a honey or something like that
or like walking her to a car blah blah I
don't really take people yeah yeah you
know what I mean I've been all one-sided
time spent
[Music]
so for the record do you think over
consent is unsexy yes yeah yeah
manage that guys good
like you have this magical moment and
you're like we're going out and you're
like oh that's do you like me yeah yeah
then she says yes and then you're like
okay this is the part where we do that
now it's just no she says yes we go
that's not how I felt all right keep
asking questions yeah this is the date
yes can I can I kiss you now and then
that section the kiss she's just gonna
pull back anyways yeah may I kiss
oh
she's playing hard again you run forward
challenge soccer head butt thing
good to know athletes
I remember my first time kissing was 14
I think and then we're in our bed
and both of us don't know what the [__]
is happening and we're just making out
and then I remember just like my hands
went under her shirt like on the on in a
on her back oh wow and I remember I
touched her bra and I was like oh go to
hell
you're still going by the way how many
of you struggled with the bra dude to
this day
I I didn't the very first time and I
thought it was the [__] no way and then
every time after that I struggled you
know every time after that you had a
great showing it was really hard when
you're not looking at it because you
don't know like how it works well
because our friends were like no you
gotta use one hand or it's not cool but
I think the first time I did that the
girl was like she was she had like
bigger boobs so her bra was like kind of
like waiting to pop out so it's mad easy
just go test yeah but then later in life
like you get different types of bras
different types of women and then you
just oh I'm sorry
your boobs aren't big enough for you to
brawl wants to come could you just turn
around exactly yeah yeah yeah
right I mean sometimes it would have
just one hook in class but sometimes
they'll have like three lined up and
[__] you know what I mean they're just
like you think and you feel two of them
already you're like God why the [__] is
this stuck you know what I mean or no
like half open you know yeah
I got it and you're like [__] so you
gotta take out your butterfly knife it's
super easy and you're like all right
yeah sometimes there's like a there's a
stitching that goes like vertical that
you can kind of grab with your finger
and then you can but then sometimes it's
so smooth yeah that you're just slipping
around
perfectly yeah that's how it felt
because you could like because you can't
see it so you gotta like Braille that
[__] you're like oh there's a trail the
Frog
yeah
yeah y'all remember the first time y'all
uh got Dome
part two I remember later I remember
that [__] remember that [__]
I remember that [__]
it made the first move
thank you
[Music]